la velocidad de la luz es 3 por 10 a la
8 metros por segundo como puedes ver la
luz es bastante rápida 3 por 10 a la 8
metros por segundo si la luz tarda 5 por
10 a la 2 segundos en viajar desde el
sol a la tierra pensemos en esto 5 por
10 a la 2 segundos son 500 segundos
si hay 60 segundos en un minuto entonces
480 segundos son 8 minutos por lo cual
la luz que viaja del sol a la tierra lo
hace en un tiempo de 8 minutos con 20
segundos y la pregunta es cuál es la
distancia en metros en metros entre el
sol y la tierra así es que nos dan una
taza nos dan la velocidad nos dan un
tiempo y quieren que encontremos la
distancia así es que necesitamos la
fórmula clásica de distancia es igual a
velocidad por tiempo así es que nos dan
la velocidad la velocidad es 3 por 10 a
la 8 metros por segundo
por 10 a la 8 metros por segundo esa es
la velocidad nos dan también el tiempo
el tiempo es 5 por 10 a la 2 segundos 5
por 10 a la 2 segundo a poner con una s
así es que cuál es la distancia la
distancia de en metros
podemos usar las propiedades asociativas
y conmutativa de la multiplicación con
esta expresión para que obtengamos que
esto de aquí es igual a de hecho vamos a
hacer también un análisis dimensional
donde estas unidades las tratamos como
variables para que veamos cuál es la
unidad en la que queda el resultado así
es que guarde escribir esto de la
siguiente manera 3 por 5 3 por 5 y eso
que multiplica estoy usando solo
propiedad de computa tividad y
asociatividad en estas expresiones esto
que multiplica a 10 a la 8
eso que multiplica a 10 a la 8 que
multiplica a 10 al cuadrado
multiplicando por 10 al cuadrado y ahora
hagamos el análisis mención al esto es
metros por segundo que multiplica a
segundos entonces tratando esto como
variable simplificamos segundos en el
denominador y el numerador y me queda en
metros que lo que queremos queremos la
distancia precisamente en metros
así es que esto es igual a 3 por 5 15
que multiplica a 10 a la 8 por 10 al
cuadrado tenemos la misma base de 10
podemos sumar los exponentes
esto sería 10 a la 8 2 10 a la 8 + 2 que
es 10 a la 10 y podrías pensar que ya
hemos concluido que ya está notación
científica pero no recuerda que para que
esto esté notación científica este
término tiene que ser un número que esté
entre 1 y 10 y 15 es un número mayor a
10 así es que tenemos que transformar
este número un número entre 1 y 10 para
eso 15 lo escribimos como 1.5 que es
claramente un número mayor que un y
menor que 10
y para que no se altere 15 es igual a
1.5 por 10 a la 1 y para ver que esto es
así suponemos que aquí 15 tiene un punto
decimal esto es 15.0 y entonces para ir
de 15 a 1.5 dividimos entre 5 perdón
para ir de 15 a 1.5 dividimos entre 10
corremos el punto decimal a la izquierda
un lugar y al correo el punto decimal a
la izquierda un lugar obtenemos 1.5
estamos dividiendo entre 10 obtenemos
1.5 y para no modificar la expresión
tenemos que multiplicar por 10
así es que estos dos son el mismo número
así es que 15 es igual a 1.5 por 10 y
eso x multiplicado por diez
no no x sala 10 esto es multiplicado por
10 a la 10 este 10 se realmente 10 a la
1 estos exponentes se pueden sumar pues
tenemos la misma base
así es que esto es igual a 1.5 por 10
elevado a la 10 más 1 por 10 elevado a
la 11
y hemos concluido ahora si te fijas en
el resultado esto es una distancia muy
grande es exorbitante es una distancia
que es muy difícil de visualizar